- I know it's hard to pick favorites,
but what is your favorite matrix?
- (laughing) What's my favorite matrix?
Okay, so my favorite matrix
is square, I admit it.
It's a square bunch of numbers
and it has twos running
down the main diagonal.
And, on the next diagonal,
so think of top left to bottom right,
twos down the middle of the matrix,
and minus ones just above those twos,
and minus ones just below those twos.
And, otherwise, all
zeros, so mostly zeros.
Just three non-zero diagonals coming down.
- What is interesting about it?
- Well, all the different
ways it comes up.
You see it in engineering.
You see it as an ALEKS in
calculus to second derivative.
So calculus learns about
taking the derivative,
figuring out how fast
something's changing,
but second derivative,
now that's also important.
That's how fast the change is changing,
how fast the graph is bending,
how fast it's curving.
And, Einstein showed that
that's fundamental to understand space.
So second derivatives should have
a bigger place in calculus.
Second, my matrices, which are like
the linear algebra version,
of second derivatives,
are neat in, linear algebra.
Yeah, just everything comes
out right with those guys!
(laughter)
- Beautiful!